and here we go max versus max there's
max's numbers brought to you by the
pennsylvania lottery hopefully he can
finish up strong just like crow did last
night
in the center that's brian reynolds that
ball really carried yeah that had a
little backspin on it apparently
so we get that first one out of the way
i think it's the first time ever in
baseball history max faced max to start
a ball game
we saw stevenson's first career
appearance in the outfield yesterday
opposite way to right falls in and gets
on pass yoshi shishugo
stevenson smells blood he shoots up to
second races over to third they'll eat
the relay tucker lobs it in and
stevenson at third base with one out you
can almost see that coming couldn't you
you know shoshugo plays so deep in right
right field the idea is that there's no
ball that can get past him but stay in
the ballpark
castillanos
and he gets into one to left gamel makes
the catch stevenson tags throw to the
plate
no shot sac fly rbi and nick castiano's
gives the reds a one-nothing lead
granick
strikes out joey votto
change-up tyler malley having a career
year just seems to be getting better and
better all the time doesn't he he clips
the 200 strikeout mark he's got 13 wins
his earned run average is really solid
at 3.5 that is despite having a lot of
problems when he pitches at home on the
road he's lights out one of the best
pitchers in all of baseball runner at
first one out here's brian reynolds
reynolds smashed to barrero
late on the dp throw but a nice reactive
glove from guerrero
was drafted in the 11th round five years
ago out of a high school outside of
scranton he is 24 years old
and deep to left
gamma reaches up at the last moment and
makes the catch
been pretty darn good haven't he yeah i
mean he's a grinder he
you know he's not a superstar
you know we we've kind of picked him up
and indians didn't want him but
he's been great for us
plays the heck out of the outfield get
some big hits
and out is an out isn't out that's
exactly right
before the game today here's the o2
pitch
and that strike three called and down on
strikes michael chavis very quickly here
no single e8 jacob stallings
boy does he have that pitch working just
a little bit of comeback at the very
last second right there cruz in his
first major league played appearance a
warm round of applause
kicks off the mound you can get down
that line but he is retired by jose
barrero
pirates leave a man it's one nothing
since it as the shields heads into
scoring position down at second one down
and we go back to the top of the order
here's mack schrupp
schrock's shallow center gets down to
base hit around a third to shields races
to the plate and scores a blooper for
schrock
and the bunt pays immediate dividends
it's a two-nothing reds lead
bouncer
caves to tucker to moran double play
because cruz didn't throw home nice play
well done two-nothing now he's got cole
tucker
back-to-back case
four on the night for maui shugo who he
walked not a payoff his first time
mali is working tonight
strikes out the side in a perfect third
runner on it first with one man out and
the batter is a eugenio suarez he gave
one a ride his first time up 2-2
suarez good carry to center reynolds
back
saca
hey eugenio suarez launches a two-run
homer to straight center and the reds
double their lead it's four nothing well
almost right on cue so here's the
pitcher maui an opportunity for kranik
to get the third out
and he goes down on strikes
[Applause]
two in on the home run by suarez
brian reynolds will lead things off for
pittsburgh followed by colin moran and
michael chavis
brian reynolds who lined out his first
time
spanked that one down the line and gets
nabbed at second base max schrock drops
the tag
and a greedy reynolds
gunned down by friedel but in this case
in this lineup tj friedl who can play a
very fine center field gets there
quickly gets rid of it online nice one
hopper
runs aboard and that'll bring up michael
chavis
rounded to short barrero feed shrock
double play
two gone here in the fifth inning nick
castillano sac flying at a flyout
nick castellanos
leaves the yard again
his 34th home run he has 99 rbis right
center field between right and left
center field between the gaps and that
is a
big man's part of the ballpark out there
where he just went there's two on for
o'neal crews who comes up
ground ball right field base hit o'neil
cruz
for a waves home the run
oh neil cruz his second major league at
bat produces
his first big league hit and first major
league ribbie wilmer defoe will pinch
hit or delos santos
drive right center we're gonna find out
stallings just now getting around third
and crows is right on his tail defoe's
headed to third
and that's a trip
trip
triple and the bucks are back in it on
the wilmer defoe
three base hit he is moving he's going
through the shortstop position about six
strides and boom he's home not even a
play cole tucker four straight hits off
mally here in this fifth inning
a little tapper this will do it making a
one-run game and tucker is gonna beat it
out
and now michael chamus a right-handed
batter will come to that headless in two
trips tonight but he'll bat with two
aboard
ground ball that is a fair ball over the
bag
tucker will score
reynolds will score
look at this the pirates have come
storming back
and they love it here in pittsburgh it
is remarkable what this team has done
they can come from behind and now o'neil
cruz will bat for the second time in the
inning
goes down on strikes damage done a sixth
run the reds have two on with two out
and here's tyler stevenson
breaking ball stevenson to left field
down base hit
freidle scores stop sign at third for
schrock stevenson into second a game
tying standing double
it's now six six and here is castianos
and a play made by moran and on to meers
for the last out of the sixth inning
reds tie it
6-6
put a runner on with two outs for brian
reynolds
rips it to right field
tsutsugo does not run well
and it kicks away from castillanos
so korra waves home
yoshi and into third goes reynolds
and it is 7-6 pirates two out single
that brings up o'neill cruz
that's a line shot to right field
check out the exit velo on that one
[Applause]
118.2 miles an hour look how ball oh
my god and tucker who hit a grand slam
last night has a chance for another one
that was the first and it's an rbi walk
for cole tucker and an 8-6 pirates lead
nick castianos at the plate
dribbler moran
stratton raise the jolly roger
another comeback